Nina Jérémy vous êtes en couple depuis
quatre ans merci d'être là les chéris
merci à vous vous êtes rencontré comment
sur les réseaux les réseaux où ça insta
bah j'ai envoyé un message à Nina mais
ça va un peu ringard c'est quoi le
message en fait je lui ai dit on peut se
croiser vous sur Nice d'accord
pas mal pas mal quand tu as rencontré
Nina euh donc raconte-nous parce que au
départ quand tu la contactes tu tu l'as
vu sur les réseaux tu as craqué pour
elle exactement ouais je savais pas du
tout qui a été qui était trans donc
c'est venu avec le temps comme on a
parlé et du coup moi j'ai accepté
directement la chose j'ai pas j'ai pas
été dans le jugement j'ai euh t'en a
parlé elle t'a dit quand bah en fait
directement directement il voulait pas
me cacher la chose avant que vous
rencontriez ou bien non non et après tu
le dis en fait physiquement j'étais déjà
très féminine c'est juste que j'avais
pas fait ma féminisation faciale ni ma
poitrine et en fait rien quoi d'accord
ouais mais c'était quand même très fin
j'avais les cheveux longs d'accord et
donc tu n'es pas opéré quoi et donc à un
moment dans la dans la conversation tu
lui as dit parce que je voulais pas
m'attacher un garçon surtout que moi
c'était mon premier copain parce que
pour moi c'était hors de question que je
me mette en couple en sachant que
j'étais pas opéré avoir une relation
sexuelle avec un garçon c'était hors de
question mais du coup il m'a mis en
confiance on n'a pas de suite parler de
sexe tout ça il a vraiment appris à me
connaître et à vouloir apprendre mon
histoire et c'est ça qui m'a beaucoup
plu chez lui c'est pour ça que j'ai
laissé rentrer dans ma vie que
maintenant ça fait 4 ans donc toi tu
t'es dit quoi toi tu t'es dit ça ça
m'est tombé dessus quoi
au début
beaucoup de questions sont posées parce
que faut savoir après j'ai mis je
connaissais pas du tout
expliquer on a beaucoup parlé quoi je
savais pas trop donc du coup je l'ai
posé beaucoup de questions et puis après
j'ai accepté la chose quoi c'est alors
tu hésites pas à montrer sur ton Tik Tok
des photos de toi avant la
transformation est-ce que tu m'autorises
à ce qu'on montre les photos de toi
avant regarder
donc ça c'est moi quand j'étais petite
ça c'était moi un peu plus jeune pendant
l'adolescence voilà on commence un peu à
mettre du rose on commençait un peu à se
chercher c'était moi un tout petit peu
avant ma transition donc vous voyez je
me maquillais je faisais le teint je me
faisais les sourcils ça c'était moi donc
pendant ma transition au tout début donc
vous voyez je commence à laisser pousser
mes cheveux je me maquillais je
commençais à être un peu plus féminine
et voilà c'est temps après après une
féminisation faciale une augmentation
mammaire et un changement de sexe mais
voilà c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
franchement c'est incroyable et là tu te
sens bien la théorie 6 ans donc
franchement tu es heureuse ah ouais en
plus tu as trouvé l'amour en plus pas
c'était pas prévu mais
c'est génial une chance de fou quoi
c'est vraiment une chance
dis-moi la vérité comment on réagit tes
proches parce que c'est vrai que ça
aussi
[Musique]
[Rires]
après moi je suis quelqu'un je m'en fous
du regard des autres je parce que tu as
craqué sur insta exactement au départ
c'est quoi tu l'as vu sur des photos
c'est ça c'est que des photos et quand
tu l'as vu tu t'es dit de toute façon je
sais que quoi qu'il arrive voilà c'est
la bonne personne en fait on a bien
échangé et moi de base je voulais déjà
me poser donc
une fois qu'on s'est vu moi pour moi
c'était pour décider du sérieux quoi
c'est simple que j'allais pas et c'est
ça et en fait après tu t'es dit de toute
façon moi je m'en fous je voilà
c'était limite mais voilà c'était je
mange j'ai trouvé la personne qui me
fallait parce que on a on a voilà
exactement qu'on s'entendait très bien
etc on s'entendait très bien mais après
il y avait toujours ce moi j'ai eu peur
de lui dire que j'étais pas opéré
forcément
un moment donné on allait voilà alors
moi je ne fais pas ça mais oui mais
du coup tu m'as dit comment tu lui as
dit comment ah ben moi je lui ai dit
directement parce que je voulais pas
m'attacher à quelqu'un il souffrir parce
que déjà c'est compliqué en tant que
femme
ah oui
peut-être le deuxième on va attendre
tout va bien au début il savait pas trop
ce que c'était une femme trans donc j'ai
expliqué ma transition vous l'avez
expliqué parce que c'est ah bah moi je
lui ai dit voilà quand j'ai pas toujours
été comme ça moi je suis né garçon voilà
petit garçon mais j'étais très très
malheureuse donc j'ai entamé une
transition je suis en monnaie ça fait ça
faisait déjà deux ans que j'étais emmené
et après je lui ai dit par contre voilà
je suis pas opéré donc je préfère que tu
me dises maintenant si ça te pose un
problème ou pas et après bah il a été
très ouvert d'esprit parce que voilà bah
il faut savoir quand il a quand même
je me suis fait opérer peut-être combien
de temps deux ans après c'était ouais un
an et demi ou deux ans après donc
pendant un an et demi deux ans
on a réussi à trouver un terrain
d'entente pour pas brusquer chacun
rester dans sa zone de confort et chacun
trouver son plaisir mais c'était
compliqué quand même surtout pour lui
bien sûr parce que c'est incroyable
avec ta famille elle a dit quoi bah très
bien
repas de famille non non et même moi bon
après alors toi toi
ta famille ils ont agi comment moi ma
famille j'ai eu énormément de chance de
ce côté là mes parents ils m'ont hyper
bien accepté mes frères et sœurs aussi
et j'ai beaucoup de chance de ce côté là
et lui bah il a été très bien accepté
aussi dans la bien sûr parce que c'est
quelqu'un de gentil d'ouvert d'esprit
c'est et aujourd'hui au niveau de voilà
dans le le regard des autres voilà il
est pour vous voilà donc vous nous dit
tout se passe bien vous êtes heureux
vous travaillez tous les deux
Tik Tok d'accord ça cartonne
j'ai fait la couverture de passion
fougasse
vous dites que vous êtes également sur
Tik Tok et que vous montrez votre
histoire et votre couple il y a aussi
une démarche j'allais dire presque
pédagogique de montrer cette histoire
qui se passe bien qui va bien démarche
en faisant Tik Tok de partager mon
histoire d'aider aussi et de et puis
après moi j'estime avoir fini ma
transition donc je trouvais que j'avais
vraiment tout vécu pour permettre d'en
parler etc et puis ça aide énormément de
gens parce que je reçois énormément de
messages et voilà les démarches tout ça
moi j'aurais aimé que quelqu'un m'aide
comme ça au début de ma transition pour
me un peu me conseiller et me guider
mieux j'ai une question pour vous deux
comment vous ferez pour fonder une
famille c'est ça ça c'est une bonne
question alors excuse-moi
c'est ce qu'on nous dit tout le temps
sur Tik Tok aussi parce que
malheureusement il y a plein de gens qui
pensent que être une femme c'est donner
la vie mais malheureusement il y a plein
de femmes six heures aussi qui ne
peuvent pas tomber enceinte
naturellement donc moi forcément j'ai
pas le système reproductif d'une femme
j'ai pas d'Auber j'ai pas de l'utérus
donc je ne peux pas avoir d'enfant
naturellement mais comme plein de
couples hétéro 6 bah on restera on fera
un meilleur porteuse et puis peut-être
qu'on en aura pas non plus parce que une
vie enfin une vie accomplie c'est pas
forcément non plus une vieille qui est
des enfants donc on verra mais en tout
cas c'est pas un problème c'est fou mais
c'est une belle c'est une très belle
histoire hein vous êtes amoureuse aussi
un Jérémy franchement il a l'air
franchement intelligent on va fêter nos
quatre ans en août là on fait quoi c'est
quoi la soirée
venez tous à Nice
à côté de Nice à côté de Nice
[Musique]
je souhaite à toutes les femmes trans de
trouver une histoire d'amour comme ça
parce que malheureusement
on va pas se mentir dans la société
d'aujourd'hui la femme trans c'est hyper
sexualisée ça reste encore un peu un
fantasme et moi je trouve que ma
démarche allait bien parce que on peut
être une femme trans à avoir une vie
complètement normale je suis vraiment
voilà
[Musique]
merci à vous deux